[Musica]
sono le sei del mattino di una calda
giornata d'estate e il 3 agosto e ci
sono tre navi pronte a salpare dai porti
spagnoli su una di queste la più grande
c'è cristoforo colombo che sta guardando
l'infinito e sa che dentro di sé
nonostante tutti i rischi sta per
cambiare la storia
facciamo un piccolo passo avanti e il 12
aprile 1981 e dal mission contro sente
di huston si sente lift off quando per
la prima volta lo space shuttle accende
i suoi rombanti motori e si leva verso
il cielo a bordo di quello shuttle c'è
john young che ha le sue mani sui
comandi e sa che nonostante i rischi sta
aprendo una nuova pagina
dell'esplorazione spaziale
eccolo sentite anche voi quella
sensazione che sfide incredibili possono
essere trasformate in veri traguardi
quando tante persone collaborano insieme
io sì e credo prima di tutto che parto
dal sognare
siamo abituati a pensare che il segnale
sia qualcosa di lontano come una fetta
di torta alla fine del pasto della
realtà ma il segnale è il passo centrale
della nostra vita perché ci dice chi
siamo e cosa vogliamo diventare
ritornata quando per la prima volta vi
siete chiesti cosa voglio fare nella
vita
e forse la domanda più importante che
nessuno ma non si possa porre perché ciò
che si definisce ciò che si rappresenta
che ci dà un senso in che modo vogliamo
contribuire alla società con le nostre
caratteristiche e doti naturali che cosa
vogliamo dare al mondo e che cosa
vogliamo prendere indietro
ecco per spiegarmi in che modo
l'esplorazione spaziale può far parte di
questa risposta però facciamo un passo
indietro e il 2003 lo space shuttle
columbia sta rientrando dalla sua
ventottesima missione con a bordo una
crew di astronauti interdisciplinari
giovani e multietnici
pochi secondi dopo le 9 però lo space
shuttle si disintegra
portando con sé tutto l'equipaggio io mi
ricordo che quando è successo
avevo 11 anni e ho sentito la notizia
mentre mi stavano preparando pranzo ho
preso un poster dello shuttle che avevo
ricavato da un giornale sono corsa in
camera allora appeso sopra il mio letto
e mi sono messa a piangere di rabbia
perché pensavo alla crew che era appena
andata perduta
pensavo alle famiglie che li aspettavano
al pub in florida
pensavo anche al team che li aveva
supportati fino a pochi secondi prima
dal mission control center di huston
pensavo un'intera nazione che stava per
entrare in lutto e l'inaccettabilità del
perdere vite umane o però compreso
profondamente che cosa avesse spinto
quella crew a farsi scegliere per la
missione nonostante i rischi
l'esplorazione spaziale la sfida che ci
poniamo in quest'epoca siamo la stessa
umanità che 117 anni fa per la prima
volta si alzava dal suolo terrestre meno
di 58 anni dopo alcune delle stesse
persone che avevano visto i fratelli
wright volare hanno potuto assistere
all'essere umano che valica i confini
dell'atmosfera entrava nello spazio dal
primo novembre 2000 la stazione spaziale
internazionale continuativamente abitata
segnando 20 anni di permanenza umana
nello spazio
siamo una specie incredibile siamo in
grado di costruire mezzi di trasporto
intelligenti ottimizzare l'agricoltura
portare avanti lotte per i diritti e per
la salvaguardia dell'ambiente e meno di
100 anni siamo passati da non esserci
mai alzati dal solo terrestre a vivere
nello spazio ora immaginate che cosa
possiamo fare oltre lo spazio non ha
confini
non c'è la cima di una montagna da
raggiungere il fondale di una fossa
marina o il nucleo al centro della terra
lo spazio alla frontiera infinita dove
il limite viene spostato un po più in là
da ogni ricerca spedizione precedente lo
spazio anche l'ultima frontiera quella
dove l'essere umano si conferma una
specie di esploratori ed i sognatori
dove all'acume all'ingegno
l'intelligenza però si unisce anche un
senso di squadra un senso di obiettivo
di sacrificio anche di voler ridare
indietro
resto dell'umanità un nuovo benessere e
come me l'esplorazione spaziale entra
tutti i giorni nella nostra vita è
presente quando ci connettiamo internet
da tutte le parti del mondo è presente
le nostre tasche quando nei cellulari
abbiamo dei microchip che sono
estremamente più potenti dei computer
che hanno portato l'essere umano sulla
luna è presente anche nella composizione
particolarmente in un cliente di alcuni
alimenti per neonati è presente anche
nella serenità con la quale accediamo
cure mediche come la risonanza magnetica
oppure veniamo trattati per malattie
come il parkinson o l'alzheimer o anche
il cancro che sono tutte state studiate
in microgravità lo spazio che quindi di
fatto ci sta così vicino ci appare però
lontano come un ambito per addetti ai
lavori per quei pochi ingegneri che
lavorano sulle rampe di lancio per
quegli scienziati che pensano gli
esperimenti per la stazione spaziale o
quei pochi astronauti che ci salutano da
dentro le tute non è così
niente di più sbagliato lo spazio è
nostro quello che cercherò di
comunicarvi oggi esattamente questo
lo spazio e di ognuno di noi
noi siamo la cosiddetta generazione
artemis artemis artemide e la dea la
sorella di apollo che dà il nome alle
missioni che caratterizzeranno questa
nostra epoca
stiamo per tornare sulla luna ma questa
volta per restarci
saremo i primi dopo 40 anni che potranno
vedere la luna è sapere che in quel
momento esseri umani come noi ci stanno
vivendo
torneremo sulla luna ma questa volta non
ci accontenteremo di prendere un
campione di solon aree tornare a casa
questa volta costruiremo una base e la
chiameremo casa una casa che proteggerà
gli astronauti dalle radiazioni spaziali
offrirà cibo ossigeno acqua e anche
tutta l'energia necessaria per
comunicare di nuovo verso terra dovete
quindi considerare un po il vivere sulla
luna come un passaggio intermedio tra
ciò che è stato considerato possibile
fino ad adesso è ciò che sarà possibile
alla fine di questo secolo perché stiamo
percorrendo una strada che ci ha portato
prima ad andare sulla luna
adesso a vivere sulla luna e poi ci
porterà su marte marte
che ci pone sfide simili a quelle della
luna in un certo senso sono sfide di
sopravvivenza ma anche economiche e
politiche
marte che può essere considerato un po
un'alternativa alla terra marte che
sicuramente potrebbe essere il nostro
avamposto verso il resto del sistema
solare perché immaginatevi di essere su
quella navicella che per prima viaggerà
verso marte non vi sentireste su di voi
un pò di stare portando le aspettative i
sogni ma anche i concreti sforzi di
un'intera specie che vi ha passato una
fiaccola un po come un tedoforo per
andare dove nessuno è mai stato e fare
luce e dire ok questa è la nostra nuova
normalità qual è la prossima frontiera e
uno spirito simile a quello che
probabilmente ha guidato colombo al
tempo e che spingerà gli astronauti
della missione artemis adesso è uno
spirito pionieristico che unisce nazioni
e popoli per lo stesso obiettivo
ed è una sfida per tutti quanti per
esempio la vostra capacità di prendere
un problema complesso e scomporlo in
tante piccole parti e poi risolverle una
una potrebbe sbloccare un problema di
pianificazione in uno di questi processi
o magari le vostre conoscenze
nell'ambito della politica o
dell'economia o del diritto potrebbero
contribuire a definire qual è la maniera
più equa per distribuire le risorse
presenti sulla luna il vostro estro
artistico potrebbe segnare un intera
generazione con un libro un film o una
canzone vivere su marte vivere sulla
luna ci pone sfide a livello di umanità
non è più soltanto una sfida per piloti
ingegneri di calcio scienziate questa
volta è l'intera umanità a essere la
somma di cristoforo colombo ed è
un'umanità che investe tutte le proprie
risorse i migliori donne e uomini per
questo obiettivo
ecco in questo contesto io ho trovato
dei mentori incredibili è
un'organizzazione che ha creduto in
questa spinta perché la stessa che l'ha
fatta nascere all'inizio e ora ci stiamo
preparando a rispondere al futuro perché
chiaramente quando si sposta un po più
in là la linea del possibile si creano
nuovi bisogni e se il nuovo possibile
sarà vivere sulla luna
avremo i cosiddetti space worker ossia i
lavoratori spaziali che vivranno li
avranno esigenze
e a quelle di una piccola città e quindi
non ci stiamo preparando per esempio
fornire loro le infrastrutture di
telecomunicazione che permetteranno loro
di comunicare verso casa quasi come se
fossero pochi chilometri per farlo
prendiamo altissime tecnologie e le
miniaturizzazione di state liti che sono
grossi come delle scatole di scarpe e
poi dopo di che li rendiamo autonomi
affidabili in grado quindi anche di
diagnosticare isolare e riparare un
malfunzionamento senza l'intervento
umano
immaginatevi di essere sul suolo lunare
alzare la testa al cielo e vedere
orbitale sopra di voi questo stormo di
satelliti sapendo che grazie a questa
the riti potete comunicare verso casa
quasi come se fosse pochi chilometri e
poi ci siamo anche occupando degli
astronauti perché ci interessa della
loro salvaguardia della salute e quindi
li stiamo addestrando a eseguire delle
procedure mediche avanzate senza il
supporto delle infrastrutture che sono
presenti sulla terra e tutto questo che
vi ho raccontato è possibile solo perché
ci sono migliaia di inclinazioni
caratteristiche caratteri diversi di
altrettante centinaia di popoli nazioni
che lavorano insieme per questo
obiettivo c'è una frase che mi ha sempre
colpito
se vuoi diventare astronauta non c'è un
percorso già scritto una strada definita
capisci chi sei
con gli cosa ti appassiona e poi
dedicati c con tutte le tue forze perché
questo farà di te un'ottima candidata
ecco questa considerazione vale per
tutti i mestieri che vi ho detto prima
non c'è una strada definita per accedere
al settore spaziale
quindi adesso tocca a voi quale sarà il
vostro posto nella ciurma di cristoforo
colombo
non importa ciò che siete stati ciò che
siete ora ciò che sarete l'esplorazione
spaziale la ricerca spaziale saranno
sempre lato attendervi grazie
[Applauso]